[Music]
on today's show we talked to a man whose
mother has cancer and she's decided to
pursue assisted suicide we talked to a
sister whose brother just came back from
deployment he's struggling with mental
health issues
when we talked to a young woman whose
six-year-old little sister just found
out dad's having an affair stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show
so glad you're with us
hope your life is going well if your
kids are doing all right
if you're a
dog parent hope that's going well
cat i can't go with cat parents i can
maybe get there with a dog i can't do
cat parents
but i hope everything's going well in
your life if your job's going good hope
your health is good if you want to be on
our show we talk about mental health
relationships
education life what to do next give us a
shout at one eight four four six nine
three
thirty two ninety one it's one eight
four four six nine three
three two nine one or go johndaloni.com
ask i think i left out a word there
johndaloni.com
ask and you can fill out the form and it
goes to kelly
and she will decide your fate
is that how that works yes kind of and
she's just nodding as a tub all right
cool let's go straight to the call
center it's good oh before we go to the
calls
dude don't forget go johndaloni.com
if you want to have a politics and covet
free
holiday season
we've created their decks of cards they
are for um
couples who are out on a date who
haven't spoken to each other with no
electronics in years or a couple years
they are for families who are sitting
around on a on vacation with their
in-laws and we were just staring at each
other and we don't know what to do next
and there are cards for parents and kids
and these are conversation starters to
get the room going some have told us man
we burned through like 10 or 15 of those
and a night is so fun others have said
we got through three because this
conversation led to that they're a
little bit twisted they're a little bit
delonified um but they are designed to
connect people to one another go
johndaloni.com pick up all three sets of
these cards they'll get you through the
holidays and they'll get you into the
new year and here's what we're doing we
are practicing
human connection and i know that we've
been so disconnected for so long we're
practicing human connection and we're
gonna get this thing right all right so
let's go to the call just go to brian in
los angeles hey brian what's going on
brother
hey how's it going
we're doing all right
how are you
good good my question is how do we
handle the fact that my mom has chosen
the death with dignity option to end her
life in the coming months oh man so what
brought her to this uh
death with dignity by the way um
that's just particular state you're in
they call assisted suicide right
correct uh so what what is
what's going on in her world
um april 2018 she got diagnosed with
stage four
glioblastoma wow
brain cancer
yep um
since then she was driving as of
probably about a year ago she's still
driving still talking still doing great
she's declining hasn't driven in a while
now because of a seizure or something
she had so
never the fact where
she is declining but
she's still able to talk to us you know
not really communicate well with the
grandkids it attacked her speech first
but
she's
it's kind of one of those weird deals
where the kind of rules in california
are
you have to be able to mix it yourself
it's a dream you have to mix it yourself
that's right take it yeah versus someone
else give it to you so you have to be
able to do it yourself so you got to
take it before you're bad enough not to
or else then you never have the option
right so it's a weird balance
well and i think the reason they do that
is twofold one is
it's it's there's still some controversy
in the medical community about
if i give you an actual if you don't mix
it yourself if you've got to go to one
pharmacy to get one thing and go to
another pharmacy to get another thing so
it's kind of it's the doctors absolving
themselves of i didn't give her that
thing she got one piece over there one
piece from over there
and the other part is it helps
my understanding is it helps delineate
those who are trying to make an
instantaneous decision and they still
have all of their
mental and physical capacity right so
absolutely um man so is she in a lot of
pain on a constant basis or she just
exhausted like walk me through where she
is
she's more exhausted her biggest thing
is she doesn't this is where you know
you know what she has three kids i'm the
youngest
um my wife and i of course would rather
take care of her than let her do this
you know other kids feel differently but
it's she's doesn't want anyone taking
care of her it's kind of the
bottom
bluntness of her personality she just
doesn't want to be a burden on anybody
but right now you know she's
she can still talk to us she's just
she's not in a lot of pain she has some
weird pain issues sometimes but nothing
that medication can't take care of has
she given herself a date
it changes daily kind of best on based
on her
i guess mood that day just as of
her sarcasm coming out probably but
she has supposedly six months take it so
right now she says february which you
know april mid april is her six month i
guess expiration date of the medicus
medication
but she we get the medication and
holding it at her friend's house until
she's ready to do it kind of thing
um
so it's just it's kind of one of those
things well what if she also decided to
do it in december or in november or
well that plays a lot you know so much
more yeah
so this what a strange place to be is
i've i've read about and um
had discussed with with you know experts
about the actual patient the actual
client here
i have never sat down and talked to
somebody whose mom has made this
decision
and it feels
unwieldy for you too huh and you got
brothers and sisters that are all in on
this
yeah so everybody knows so
you know my mom kind of just we knew
since she was diagnosed
that
like she sat us down the week after it
was like hey look like
when it comes down to this i'm gonna
fight for my right
as a californian or whatever you want to
call she's from she was a nurse in the
medical field for years so that's my
role
i want to
take this so that i'm not a burden or
i'm not in pain or that whatever reason
it is
she wanted to do it from the very
beginning
so for the past couple years you know
she's right now she's in this she says
she's in the 16th percentile of like
length of life after diagnosis
okay she gave her 18 months to 24 months
and she's at three and a half years
she's on borrowed time now anyway in her
mind correct okay in her mind even in
our mind too like we do understand like
she is living longer than usual right so
we all understand that we all understand
she is declining it is going to come
but just the fact of knowing someone's
going to commit suicide
ahead of time is like totally different
than
militant you know what i mean yeah like
it's for sure gonna happen
and you got little ones too
i got two five-year-old twins and a
three-month-old
it's louise man
and then my brother has a ten and eight
year old so it's kind of the
ten-year-old's the closest to grandma
which is you know that's up to them on
how they handle it but my five-year-olds
they know she's sick i don't think they
understand
the extent of it and they are five so
it's kind of
you know we have our own opinions but
do our opinions even matter when it's
her you know her choice to do this her
right does a lot of medical
professionals say well so that
that's the best
safest most peaceful place to be
which is a couple of things here um well
let me ask you this i don't start
answering questions that you don't want
how can i help you uh i'm as open as can
be just kind of like
how do i handle it with my i guess my
twins it's just
you know you talked about the amazon
books before you talked about you know
i'm explaining you know people are gonna
you know pass away and they had a
grandma sorry a great grandma died yeah
a little over a year ago so they kind of
understand grandma went to heaven you
know stuff like that right i understand
and doesn't really bother them you know
i had a little brother actually i was
actually the third fourth poor child
little brother died when i was
eight and he was two and i don't really
have that my sister of course she's you
know six years older than me four years
older than sorry she's
has
that in her head right so he remembers
all that
where i don't have that trauma i don't
worry about my kids as much i worry more
i guess about
my feeling my wife's feelings and how
we're gonna handle you know the anger
and the difference in grieving and all
that it's like okay we're gonna get a
phone call one day saying hey i'm gonna
take the pill in three days or something
right right we call it the pill but it's
just
the drink yeah
all right so here's our walk through
with you
and this is just my thoughts on this and
obviously you and your wife are going to
do what you are going to do but here's
my thoughts on it
the first thing is i want you to be
angry at cancer not at mom
and you named a couple of things that um
i've heard about i've had conversations
about and i've read about which is
suicide often comes down to this it
hinges on this perceived burdensomeness
there is the
um i'm in pain or i want the pain just
to stop
or i have a bleak future but often it
will hinge on
this third leg of the stool which is
people are better off with me not here
and that's where a lot of folks will
lean into and say well you were
misguided there
your mom has a unique seat in this is
that she's been a healthcare
professional she has watched people
deteriorate and get sick and lose their
faculties
and i do understand
um i have a different perspective of
pain and death having sat in crisis
response stuff
and so i have a different person my dad
is a homicide detective has a very
different picture of death and the
reality and those kind of so a lot of
people who see it up close have a very
different perspective than those of us
than those others who
death is more
ethereal it's a it's an idea we know
it's gonna happen we don't really know
what it looks like and how it feels on
that
i sympathize with your mom feeling like
her body was taken from her
and she will exact control one last time
there's a part of me that wraps my head
around that
and who feels like my body betrayed me
but i will go out on my terms
and i don't ask us a lot you know do we
approve or do we understand i'm like mom
i don't approve but like i can say i
understand where you're coming from but
you can't ever say i approve of it you
know what i mean it's one of the rights
right
so what i want yeah and i don't want to
get into the there's so i mean within
the medical community within the
with every community's got their
thoughts and opinions on this i don't
want to get into it
but i want to get into the situation you
find yourself in this and so here's
here's what i'm doing if i'm you
i would make peace with my wife
that this is happening
and
every one of our parents will pass away
at some point period
the the
i've sat with too many people who it was
a shock it just came or they found out
that their you know dad had cancer and
he was gone in three months or there was
a car wreck or phil or you know a acute
suicide right whatever the thing is
not that this is going to be wonderful
and feel good but you do have a snapshot
in history where you can say the things
that you want to say
like i love you and i'm glad you were my
mom
and
here's a letter that i want you to read
about the impact you made in my life
um here are some letters that some cards
that the kids made because they know mom
uh grandma's really really sick
and you can choose that route
and basically someone has said i'm
taking this train
you can give them peace on that ride or
you can say
i want you to know as you take this and
drink that you're betraying your son
and you can let the let her leave with
resentment anger and frustration and
sadness
that's really the two places that i i i
think that you find yourself in
and i'm always going to choose the
hospitable route unless it is you know
it's somebody causing somebody else pain
in in our immediate sphere that's a
whole other conversation so
your grief and your wife's grief and
your heart brokenness and all that kind
of stuff i get that and that's real and
that is y'all's grief
but i want that grief as much as
possible anchored into the cancer to the
realization that this
evil disease stole your your mom from
you
not that she chose to go three months
early or four months early or two months
early does that make sense
oh 100
um i do think your five-year-olds um
i think a conversation about grandma's
real real sick
and she's not going to be with us for a
whole bunch a whole lot longer
let's write her cards let's draw her
pictures um if we see her let's talk to
her and give her hugs
um my wife did a great job at this when
my her grandmother was in a home and she
was um had dementia she was slowly
passing away it's just letting our kids
know that every one of these visits is
precious
and precious looks like holding hands
precious looks like sitting in laps
precious looks like
um
saying with respect i can't understand
you can you say that again
and it was hard it was heartbreaking but
it made the funeral a moment of
celebration not a moment of shock
and it gave us a language for six months
later when it's like hey we're gonna go
see a great grandma and it's like well
great grandma passed away
and so we were able to have that
conversation because we laid the
groundwork up close i mean up up river
if that makes sense
um
i'm sorry man
thank you i hate this for you
and i especially hate it because you've
got brothers and sisters that are all
over the place and it feels isolating
and lonely huh
uh somewhat yes
it's okay to say it i know you're tough
hardcore it's a whole it's a whole
another
phone call on that
brothers
one
sisters always are right
yup yup um
here's one gift you can give your mom
ask her
what does she want her last days to look
like
say mom i know you've made this decision
you know what i think about it and
that's the last i'm gonna speak on it i
want to
extract every ounce of joy and
connection with you that i can in the
last few months that you choose
what do you want this to look like
lots of visits you want to sneak away go
to heavy metal concert together do you
want to eat cheeseburgers every time
you want to just eat a steady diet of
gummy candies and i'm projecting a bit
here what do you want the last few
months to be
and i can't think of a greater gift you
could give somebody who's made up this
decision who's got a terminal
diagnosis
who's feeling their body leave them
every day
to say how can we honor you in this last
season
in that moment of service that's a gift
you can give to your five-year-olds and
they are not old enough to understand
you know assisted suicide dying with
disney they don't need to know any of
that stuff at all
um but they do need to know hey
grandma's asked us to come see her she's
very very sick and we're gonna go this
is this is what love looks like
and you can give her an opportunity to
speak into her final days
the whole thing is heartbreaking and i'm
so sorry and it starts with the cancer
and it starts with these hard
conversations and that i can't imagine
pulling my kids together and say hey
kids
i'm making the choice to be out but i
also understand it too hard hard season
for you and your family
confront it directly walk into it and if
you're me
if i'm you i'm making the choice to
[Music]
extract as much joy as possible out of a
messy situation thank you so much for
the call brother we'll be right back on
the dr john delonay show
[Music]
hey what's up this is john let's talk
about a good night's sleep
it's important for your physical health
your mental health your sanity you name
it if you're not sleeping good the first
question i want you to ask yourself is
do i need a new mattress and here's how
you tell if you're tossing and turning
all night because you can't get
comfortable if you woke up at night and
you're all hot right or if in the
morning your back hurts if you have any
of these issues you may need to check
out a new mattress
if you're ready for a new mattress i
want you to check out dreamcloud it's
the mattress i own and you'll love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer
bucks
ever
accessories plus an additional 250
discount only for delony listeners
that's a total of about 650 dollars in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
delony or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress today and
enjoy 650 bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y good night
all right let's go to jennifer in
orlando what's up jennifer
how are you doctor john well you're
rocking on this morning how about you
i'm doing okay
awesome so how can i help
no awesome i take that back okay he's
not awesome
i kind of just i appreciate it i kind of
say awesome about every positivity
honestly no i need to back that thing up
so you said okay and i'll say oh what's
going on jennifer
no i appreciate the positivity i need it
well it can be a little bit toxic
sometimes so what's up man
um so my brother he just returned from a
deployment overseas
and i believe that he's having a mental
health crisis and he
does not want me to tell my parents how
old is he
he is 27.
and
so a little bit of background i moved to
florida
and basically my whole family followed
me here
you said that with like and they're like
my
my son will say his little sister keeps
following him around you're like i'm
moving well that's exactly how it went
awesome
my whole family followed me here my
parents was about two hours away and my
brother moved into the same area as me
uh he's met he's married i'm married uh
we're only a few years apart i'm older
than him
[Music]
and he came here and he told me he's
always had
mental health issues growing up um i as
far as i knew it wasn't
um it wasn't like
severe
um he had oh he was diagnosed with adhd
and
um dyslexia when we were kids and he
always had trouble learning then he
wanted to he went into the military he
got married just a couple like a year
ago
and um he came here and he had told me
and my husband that he was diagnosed
again with adhd and they put him on
medication
and um he ended up staying with us for a
month before he moved in and things
seemed okay he seemed really good him
and his wife seemed really happy and you
know things seemed really good
and one night
um
it one night it like it all like came
crashing down i
i i was home and he his wife came home
and
she said that um
i said hey where's you know where's my
brother and she's like what do you mean
i thought he was here and i was like no
he's not here
he got drunk and he came home and he got
in a car
and he was driving
his convertible drunk up and down the
highway
and he came back and he almost crashed
the car into the garage
and and i free of course i freaked out
because i've never seen him do this and
i've never seen him act like this and
he was cr he was hysterically crying and
he was you know had a meltdown and told
me that he wasn't okay that he felt
crazy
then the next the next day i confronted
him about it and he said i'm just sorry
he's like i'm so sorry you see that i
just i'm i wasn't in a good place but
i'm better now i feel okay i feel good
i'm like okay like i'll just i was like
okay
all right you know what let me just see
how this goes yeah that was two weeks
ago and uh last night he
or sorry saturday night he
went out again
and
his wife was calling him and he
disappeared
we couldn't find him for hours until he
called my little sister who's about 10
years younger than us
to come pick him up because he's at a
gas station and his phone was dead and
he never got into the uber that his
friends called for him to go home
and um
my sister picked him up and the same
thing again he was crying really
frustrated very just in
duress you could tell he was just not
okay so i i i wasn't out of town when
this happened and like i said my
sister's much younger than us so she
called me and she said hey listen i
found him do you want to talk to him he
was sober at this point so the next day
and the same thing i'm so sorry i did
this to you i'm so sorry
um it won't happen again i don't have
again and i said hey
we need to tell
our parents
like i can't i feel like i ca i can't
help you i feel like i don't have the
tools to even support you at this point
and he got really upset and he said no
please no no i do know that my parent my
dad especially is a trigger for him
my dad is very
he can be very hot-headed
you know he's retired law enforcement
he's kind of he can be kind of insane
and
you know
put it to put it nicely i'm only
laughing because i may know a few of
those
yes
so i don't know i don't know what to do
at this point his wife doesn't know what
to do i don't know what to do my sister
doesn't know what to do we don't know
how to move forward well so number one
man this guy won the lottery with you as
a sister
good for you it's awesome
and
good for you for several things one for
being somebody that he trusts and being
somebody that
loves him
and
not
knowing enough to know i need to do
something and i want to make sure i do
this right so good for you on all counts
that's awesome
um
i have found that returning veterans are
some of the best in on the planet
at
putting on a brave face until that face
literally that mask literally melts off
their their body
and when you said things just seemed
really good
i can't tell you how many times i've
heard that exact phrase on the front end
of
a
combat veteran imploding
things seem so good until they just
aren't
and i think it's because there's such a
culture and there's just a necessity
right i don't you don't someone's
shooting at you or you are busy
protecting fill in the blank you know i
don't have time for my feelings right
now i got to keep everybody alive it
doesn't mean the feelings go away they
just
they just extract under pressure and get
get stronger and stronger really until
they finally implode
um your instinct is right the things you
just told me make me very concerned for
your brother
and
i would look at all like you hear me say
all the time behaviors of language he is
screaming for somebody to help him
and the words he's using are i'm all
cool everything's fine
you know they're not fine i know they're
not fine everyone around him knows
they're not fine
and i also want to honor the fact that
your dad's not a safe place
and that some of the
childhood stuff
you know he's been on a trajectory for a
long long time
and so
here's how i would handle that if i were
you
i would get his wife and get you and
your little sister
and i would circle up and say here's
your options number one we are calling
somebody
whether that's the va
whether that's a local
counseling resources and one of us is
going with you probably his wife would
be best unless he asks you specifically
to come
but this isn't a
we're thinking about it this is gonna
happen
and so you have some options as to
if you just absolutely one thousand
percent say no va no va no v and i've
met a few folks there great i'll support
you on that
um
if you say no to these things then i
then you have exceeded my capacity to
help you and i'm gonna reach out to mom
i'm gonna reach out to i'm gonna call
9-1-1 on you because you're not safe and
right now you're being not safe you're
going to hurt somebody else too
right
and so i would frame it in you get to
choose which which call i make but i'm
making a call and if you choose to not
make a call then i'm going to default to
what i know
and actually you know what i after i say
that a lot i'm going to take back what i
just said i don't think your dad's a
good idea i don't
okay and that may be your safest place
but i would reach out to a professional
community right now whether that's a
psychologist a counselor somebody who
specializes with veterans in your area
or somebody or somebody at the va you
say he's not okay right now
okay
he needs people to love him beyond what
he's asking for right now
and this will be hard on you and he will
probably say things like you're screwing
me over you don't love me i asked
specifically for this you're just trying
to punish me and you're gonna have to
love him through that
and just know that on the other side of
this
he will hug you tighter than you've ever
been hugged in your life
saying thank you okay okay
and maybe you and his wife and your
little sister circle up is there anybody
else in his immediate circle does he
have one or two
um buddies from the service that are
around that you could reach out to also
he doesn't have anybody in the service
but we do have a pretty close um circle
of friends here okay there's about two
or three of them
i would include them and if you can get
one or two men involved i think that's
helpful too
okay my experience with veterans is that
there's something there's a just a
they just are trained hierarchical and
there's something about another guy
saying this is happening
and i'm looking in the eyes right now
this is going to happen and we want you
to help
participate in what's coming but this is
happening
okay and that doesn't mean he's got to
go away for 30 days it doesn't mean he's
got to be institutionalized nothing like
that
he has to begin meeting with somebody
today or tomorrow really quick okay and
so okay good for you sister god he's
lucky to have you
good for you and thank you for saying
something call me back after that
conversation cause it's not gonna be
easy it's gonna be hard if i say that it
may be he may just his shoulders may
drop and he may weep from a place that
he hasn't wept from a long time
um
what i will tell you is this
the other side of this whole
conversation is not making a call
not doing anything
and if he ends up
dead
if he ends up hurting somebody
it will be an
ugly trip to to look in the mirror there
when you know i should have made a call
that's not why you do this i just want
to let you know on the other side of
that the about the weight of not doing
anything right now is so unreasonable to
risk
um your brother's worth loving past how
mad he's gonna be
good for you good for you golly we need
more people like jennifer in the world
if you see something say something
even if it's gonna be uncomfortable even
it's gonna cause a mess even it's gonna
cause fights and yelling and whatever
there comes a moment when we're gonna
say
[Music]
i'm making a call
you can help decide where we're gonna
call but i'm making a call
i mean more people like you in the world
jennifer thank you so much for loving
your brother like you do we'll be right
back on the dr john owens show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's take
uno mas let's go to berta in monterey
california what's up berta
hi john how are you
nervous
oh don't be i'm terrible at this
we'll figure this out together no
worries at all i'm nervous too it's all
good okay
so um
first
what is
what's your what's your full original
name is it berta
no it's roberta roberta
and then when did it switch from roberta
to my middle name is robert
i thought we were gonna have a moment
here but you screwed it up and started
calling it berta so
when did you switch to that name
um well it's a family name so my grandma
was roberta and then everybody called
her roberta so everybody called me
little bert so it kind of always
yeah so is there an obligation that if
you ever have kids you got to name one
of them roberta
no
this stops with me good job
all right so what's up how can i help
hey so um i'm the oldest of five kids
and
how old are you
i'm 27. okay
um
then my sister's 25 so we're pretty
close and then we have two they're
turning 18 this year
um and then the youngest is only six
years old she surprised everybody when
she showed up
hello
turning six huh very cool so she has
like 11 parents right
pretty much yeah she does have a lot of
parents oh man okay so you gotta
you've got a hundred brothers and
sisters one of them is six all right yes
um well my one that's closest to me in
age um for a couple months she's been
like questioning
with me she's like
hey i think dad's talking to somebody um
who's not mom
what do you think and i'm like hey
that's not our situation
like dad's just super friendly with
everybody
um let's not push that don't read into
it too much because you're reading it
you're gonna find something
um
and then
my dad and the six-year-old were at my
house the other weekend and the
six-year-old brought me that phone and
says who's dad texting i love you too
um
yeah
so
and what did you do
i looked at it and i told her oh it's
just a co-worker says like don't worry
about it it looks like they're joking
over something and she's like okay can i
play video games
so
i feel like she kind of brushed it off
but i mean if she brought it to me yeah
she didn't brush it off how many times
she brought this up
she's only brought it to me the one time
okay so just that one time
yeah they live six hours away from me
okay so
i have no idea what she's asking at home
gotcha
um
so when you saw that text
you're wise
you're an older sibling you've seen the
world
is it what you think it is
um it's definitely what i think it is
definitely what my other sister thinks
it is
so did you scroll up was there some more
shadiness
um i didn't scroll up i saw the message
it had lots of hearts and kissy faces
and stuff on it and i'm just like and i
just put it down i'm like i don't need
to see anymore yeah part of your soul
died so i was yeah that was my first
question i i do
i tell everybody i love them um i i've
got a core group of friends men and
women that i've had in my life for years
and years and years and it's important
to me
i've worked around
people
tragedy so long that i want everyone to
know the last time i talked to you i
said i love you except for james and
kelly i never tell them that
um but
this is different clearly i don't put
smiley faces in hearts and kissy faces
after everything so um
wow all right so what's next steps for
you
um well i didn't want to
say anything in front of my little
sister because
she's little
so i waited until they had left and i
called my dad and i'm like hey this
isn't okay
um i kenzie is the one that found it the
baby's the one that found it um
so obviously
mom probably knows if kenzie knows
um maybe
maybe i don't know and he didn't really
say anything he kind of just listened to
me and then hung up the phone he's hung
up
not really he's like okay
love you
bye
that's literally the strangest response
to getting busted i've ever heard
yeah
um
my dad is not good at confrontation in
words well clearly because hey dad i
just found evidence you're having an
affair all right see you later
we love you
wow
so
okay so how can i help
i'm just curious like
what
do i do if anything next because
i told him he needs to talk to mom and
he's like okay and then it just hasn't
like i've been getting texts from mom
that would just seem fine like
everything is normal but i haven't heard
from my dad until like
two weeks
okay
i'm just curious like do i need to tell
mom
like i don't know like i if i was in
that situation i want somebody to tell
me yeah that's how i feel about it part
of me as you're saying this part of me
is like man this is not my circus and
part of it is no you brought this to my
house
and
you have put me in a position
where
either i have to
pull the pin on the grenade you put in
my living room or i have to lie and hold
secrets from my mom
and i my
initial default is i don't keep secrets
from
my mom like that
and so what i would do is
get back in touch with dad
and shoot him a text and say we need to
talk today
and then ask him have you talked to mom
because i haven't heard anything
and say you've got 48 hours and then i'm
calling mom
yeah
the other part of it is he actually
called my other sister who like was
suspecting all this
and
like confessed to her and told her
instead of calling me back and saying
yeah yeah or anything
and then he was asking his mom knows and
he kept avoiding the question yeah of
course no i mean yeah
now he's put you and your sister in a
position to where
um i mean
i mean i don't want to talk bad about
your dad that's a pretty cowardly move
because he's basically made it y'all's
issue now
and
now y'all are quickly in danger of your
mom not trusting you and rightfully so
because y'all are holding stuff
yeah right so yeah i would i would have
i would tell him you got 24 hours or 48
hours and then me and sister are calling
mom especially if he confessed
everything to your other sister have
everybody are y'all oh you're six hours
away so it had to be a phone call huh
yeah it'd have to be a phone call okay
um here's here's a couple things i would
have you and your sister think through
number one what's the purpose of this
phone call
because there's a strong possibility
that you call your mom and she's like i
know i've been dealing with this for 30
years this is none of your business
that's number one number two it could be
this
now you've put her in a position to
choose her kids or her husband
and that's messy number three so you
know i'm saying like so what is your
purpose in this
and i would make the purpose if i'm you
the disclosure we're not gonna have
secrets like this inside this family
especially as we get up on the holidays
and
um
we're not gonna tell you what to do mom
if you tell us hey we're gonna i'm
forgiving dad it's it's been a whole
thing nobody knows what's going on
behind closed doors here i'm forgiving
him we're working on this together great
if you tell us we're burning the house
down and i'm gonna whatever i mean so i
think let her know that you will be in
support of whatever decisions she makes
and then you two have to decide what you
think of your old man
yeah
and you're gonna have to grieve that
because that's gonna that just sucks
yeah it does um does this surprise you
or no
um
not
not really he's never done anything like
that with
um
mom but technically me and my older
sister have a different mom and that's
how
they ended
but that was
15 years ago
so y'all you and your sister
he had y'all too with another mom and
then he cheated on that woman with your
mom with with
the new mom
no it was another woman in between
and
she's gone and then
we all really love the woman he's
married to now and she pretty much we
all call her mom we respect her as mom
do you hear the words you're saying when
i just said hey has this happened before
and you're like no but
uh yeah several times actually yeah yeah
yeah yeah this just sucks i'm sorry yeah
i'm sorry that this fell in your lap it
shouldn't have and it did and yeah
somebody's got to be the adult in the
situation and unfortunately it's not
your dad it's y'all
yeah and i i personally i'm not gonna
approach it from a gotcha or a can you
like an indignant rage
this is simply this came this is
happening
um mom and we're heartbroken and we're
not gonna keep secrets from one another
in this house
okay and there's a way that you can be
respectful and let everybody retain
their dignity
and
then you and your sister decide like
here's how we're gonna we're gonna talk
to dad we're not gonna talk to dad we're
going to
be honest with him about how much he
broke our hearts and he blew the family
up again
and and and or we're going to say hey
man this is your life
i hate that you screwed everything up um
there's a six-year-old involved here
which is heartbreaking
there's a whole family involved here
this is a six-year-old living in this
crap you know what i mean
yeah that was ugh that was one of the
hardest things for me was
the little one yeah yeah yeah yeah but
it's hard for you to let's be honest
yeah she's sick and but
don't don't collapse your pain too
because it's real but yeah i'd call them
and say you got 24 hours 48 hours to act
like a grown-up
after acting like a child for all these
years um or i'm calling mom and me and
sister cuomo
and by the way call anyway
okay you know what i mean um she's gonna
need support and love and she's probably
thinking
oh gosh
these girls are going to side with dad
and when
it's if you all love her and you respect
her and you're heartbroken with her i
think it's important to let her know
that y'all are standing by her side
okay ugh i'm so sorry berta that just
ugh breaks my heart man
and that poor six-year-old
jeez
yeah berta one more thing that
six-year-old
she needs to know she did not break up
this family when those questions come
out over the next few years
because she'll start putting two and two
together that i picked up this phone and
i handed it to big sister and now
everything's a mess
she needs to know dad caused the mess
not her
that's gonna be a tough one to unwind
thanks for the call berta all right as
we wrap up today's show they surprised
me with surprise lyrics
oh
god i asked sarah what's your favorite
song
sarah the editor
we're doing the long version we're doing
all of this this is what they brought me
as her favorite song of all time ever
in fact i think this is the song that
she got married to this is this all you
got married to what a strange wedding
you had
yeah they but they played this as they
walked down the aisle and this was their
first dance and this was the the song
they played as they got into the car and
drove away with the cans all of it
the song is i didn't even have an author
that's how great this one is uh it was
composed by ron wasserman ron wassman
you know what ron thanks for putting
more beauty and joy in the world ron
way to go ron
song is called go go power rangers
parentheses long version close
parentheses
they've got a power and a force that
you've never seen before this is gonna
screw up the whole spotify list but
thanks everybody
they got a power and a force that you've
never seen before they've got the
ability to morph and to even up the
score no one will ever take them down oh
we're going to go through this whole
song james so you want to slow the roll
of the music here the power lies on
their side
go go power rangers
go go power rangers go go power rangers
mighty morphin power rangers and i have
the reputation of being the mature one
on the show
just saying
second verse they know the fate of the
world is lying in their hands ooh sounds
like a politician they know how to you
only use their weapons for defense that
was some propaganda shoved in there no
one will ever take them down why because
the power lies on their side
go go
power rangers
you mighty morphin power rangers i can't
take anymore this is the dr john delaney
show